a deadly and unprovoked attack on a
local beach that left one person dead
and another with permanent damage has
stymied police now for a decade yeah two
people were attacked at six mile cove on
lake mojave by a muscular killer with a
bad temper cold case detectives believe
it's a mystery that can still be solved
though the i-team's george knapp has our
story
the sign leading the six-mile cove
proved prophetic for two las vegas out
for a day at the beach on lake mojave a
few miles east of searchlight the cove
is a bit out of the way known mostly to
locals and to windsurfers leo cardenas
and his girlfriend rosa castrohone drove
from las vegas to try out leo's new
metal detector on october 24 2011 a time
of year when few campers used the beach
as leo and rosa scoured the sand they
came closer to a lone camper on the
south side of the beach and something
set him off as they got a little bit
closer to where he was camping along the
shoreline
of the lake
he
walked up on him and shot both of them
killing one right there and
seriously wounding and paralyzing the
other victim rosa was shot in the head
and died on the spot leo somehow got
back on his feet and was shot again but
was still alive detectives say the
suspect walked back to his truck grabbed
the knife and returned to stab cardenas
multiple times amazingly he was still
alive and survived a long terrible night
lying next to the body of his loved one
the next morning a visitor to the beach
came across the carnage and called
authorities metro's cold case team say
the attack was unprovoked totally
innocent not engaged in any risky
behavior whatsoever not engaged in any
aggressive behavior
all accounts they were pretty humble
docile hard-working people and they were
out there minding their own business
cardenas survived but lost the use of
his legs he's since moved to mexico
detectives don't know if the attack was
a hate crime unleashed on victims who
were both hispanic this was the
description of the killer as of 2011 he
was large over six feet tall and 200
pounds muscle bound in his late 40s to
early 50s they speculate he might be a
loner with a short fuse and a violent
past who's familiar with the area his
vehicle at the time was a tan or gold
jeep cherokee at the scene police
collected tire tracks boot prints and
dna but they have yet to find a match in
any dna database this case is solvable
they say what's needed is either a
future dna match or for someone in the
public to focus on the clues and make
the connection to an angry loner who
looked like this ten years ago somebody
might see the composite the artist's
rendition of the suspect couple that
with the vehicle type and description
and in 2011 at that location and give us
a call you know if you're wrong we'll
figure it out george knapp 8 news now
homicide detectives say that access to
dna databases is useful in helping to
solve cold case mysteries but because of
privacy concerns dna information is
often off limits for police agencies